So, the first universal principle of influence is reciprocity.
Simply put, people are obliged to give back to others the form of behavior,...
...gift or service that they have received first.
If a friend invites you to their party, there's an obligation for you...
...to invite them to a future party you are hosting.
If a colleague does you a favor, then you owe that colleague a favor.
And in the context of a social obligation,...
...people are more likely to say "yes" to those that they owe.
The second universal principle of persuasion is scarcity.
Simply put, people want more of those things they can have less of.
When British Airways announced in 2003 that they would no longer be operating...
...the twice-daily London‑New York Concorde flight...
...because it had become uneconomical to run, sales the very next day took off.